maybe the issue is no fault divorce
though right like so i i can understand
kind of like what you both are saying
like and and i i guess well like i don't
have a prenup i i wouldn't want to be
you know enter into marriage that way
but i can also understand where you know
for for a man or a woman that had built
up a lot of wealth and we're now getting
into this you know legal contract that's
um you know supposed to represent a
spiritual commitment but then we're
making it a legal contract and part of
that legal contract isn't structured
around a lifelong agreement like it used
to be because we got rid of no because
now we have no fault divorce so i can i
could understand no fault divorce i
agree yeah well and i think also and
sorry just no no the courts are heavily
biased in favor of women yeah to an
insane degree especially with children
and men well you know it's funny because
we live in this culture where no fault
divorce is the law of the land
and people will say things like well
look how often marriage ends in divorce
how could you ever be in favor of social
structures which disincentivize that or
would you know dissuade people from
getting divorced but i think what people
often miss is if young folks know
they're in an environment where divorce
is not an option i firmly believe
they're going to be more careful about
who they choose to marry and i think
also people are going to be more careful
about their decision making in general
when it comes to sexuality a lot of
people will start sleeping with someone
and as you've mentioned that releases
oxytocin and other hormones that bond
you and there are a lot of couples that
end up together because they're sexually
engaging with one another and they're
bonding but they're not actually really
good for each other and then at some
point in the marriage when the novelty
of that person wears off they get
divorced so i think it's not just that
we have no fault divorce in people who
would otherwise be staying married or
getting divorced i think they're
actually making poor choices about who
they end up marrying because of the
current status quo a starter marriage
it's like a phrase it's horrifying
that's horrible
what's that like training wheels i don't
know it's just it's something i've heard
young women talk about is like a starter
marriage or it's even worse but i've
heard young women say like you know
first marriage is for money second
marriage is for love wow wow
yeah i know i know and this is this is
this is
this is ruining relationships
it's uh we were talking about this the
other day
that uh
we're citing jordan peterson so often in
this quest he was saying something that
after 35 you better have a family
because that's when things start to
break down that that's what the
conference were you you're right or no
no no i don't i don't think so yeah when
what things start to break down when you
start you're gonna be lonely you're
gonna have no friends like if you don't
start a family around 35 you're gonna be
yeah this is colloquially called the
wall and i'm sure you've heard of it if
you've been a denizen of the internet
for any length of time all women
supposedly hit a wall when they're about
35 and if you don't have a family you
are gonna be lonely and you're gonna
have a problem you're not gonna be able
to find a good date it doesn't matter
how much money you make because that's
not what men look for in a spouse i do
think that there are exceptions to that
i i agree with you for the most part and
you know for me as a psychologist again
i've sat with women you know going
through some really rough times you know
in those situations but
there are also women that just they
never want to get married they never
want to have kids they have almost like
and i mean this in a in a loving fond
way they have a a peter pan type of
existence you know they they just want
to have their dog they want to go to
brunch they they make a lot of money and
and they're they're quite happy they
they don't want to give of themselves in
the way that it takes to be to be a wife
to be a mom so i i don't want to you
know deny that there are women for whom
that actually works out do you think
that's a chemical imbalance or is that
just natural i don't i don't think it's
a chemical imbalance you know i i i
don't know what it is but um i just
wanted to to just make make room for the
fact that while i do think it's true
what tim said for the most part and
that's definitely the majority of what i
see as a psychologist but there are
women
that just made their own thing maybe we
would just be better off if i don't know
you know women had to wear red dresses
and bonnets
it's funny because you know you so
you've sort of mentioned that being the
exception to the rule and lydia brought
up this idea of the wall part of what's
so unfortunate and really stultifying
the discourse on basically everything is
that people confuse making like a
prescriptive claim and a descriptive
claim so
by lydia mentioning that there does seem
to be this point at which it's going to
be significantly more difficult for a
woman to find a partner that she's
saying that that's good and so because
of that people are just reluctant to say
that to young women they're reluctant to
share the truth with them about what
could possibly await them if they don't
get married before a certain point of
time and i think that's really
horrendous i think that's a really
horrible thing to do to young women you
should tell them the realistic
possibilities for their life instead of
trying to claim everyone can do
everything and then having them end up
miserable because they had completely
unrealistic expectations because of you
my prediction is millennial women will
not admit it this single millennial
women they're chasing their careers
many of them are probably doing it due
to social pressures many of them are
doing it because they really want to do
it and for that i nothing but respect of
the women who are not being honest with
themselves and are more concerned about
social pressures than what they truly
would want maybe a family
i don't think they'll admit it they'll
be 40 and they'll say nope life's great
i've never been happier young women will
see it they'll be 45. i love my life i'm
single and i'm living up in the big city
they're going to be 55 and they're going
to say you know well it has its charm
they're going to be 60 and they're going
to go to the young people and say i've
made a terrible mistake don't make the
same mistake i did yeah but by that
point there's going to be a generation
or two that believed the lies
do you guys think that there's such
thing as a soul mate
no
i've wondered this because i think that
being in the wrong relationship is worse
than being single personally from my
personal experience
and so i was looking for the soul mate i
spent decades
alone lonely you know and uh
i don't know i don't think personally i
just can't i think a lot of people might
be waiting for the one and i want maybe
a mistake i wanna i wanna i wanna give
the gist of that famous uh joke uh that
i've told before
uh
there's it's you know you know the joke
about the guy in the flood and he prays
to the lord for
savior so uh i love this one this one so
much it's good there's a flood guys in
his house and he's the the news comes on
and says evacuate now and so he prays
dear lord you know i've been a faithful
servant please save me from this flood
all of a sudden a car pulls up and they
jump out and they say quick get in we're
getting out of here but the flood gets
too bad and he goes no no i'm not going
the lord will save me and they're like
you have to come with us and he refuses
after a few hours the waters have risen
so high he's reached the second floor of
his house and then once again he prays
oh lord save me i've been a you know
faithful servant and a boat pulls up to
the window and they're like quick get in
we're getting out of here
and the guy says no no the lord will
save me the waters keep rising so he
climbs up the window goes on the roof
and then he says please please lord
don't let me die
then a helicopter comes and they're like
they throw a rope down a rope ladder
down quick climb the rope later he goes
no the lord will save me
and then they're like you have to and
helicopter leaves because he won't do it
and the flood waters rise up and he dies
when he makes his way up to heaven he's
you know before god and he says i don't
understand i was i was a faithful
servant that did everything and you let
me die and he goes i sent you a car a
boat and a helicopter but the reason i
tell that joke now is i think for you
ian you're saying you you were single
for so long because you're trying to
find the soul mate perhaps you've
already met them and you just thought it
was going to be something more than it
really was you assumed the soul mate
would come down with wings floating down
before you when it was just some you
know i don't know regular looking person
who was like what up i thought that the
soul mate was going to make me better
but what i realized was i make myself
better and so she comes she arrives you
know however well the field of dreams
approach if you build it they will tell
you how you build yourself up i'm
curious what you think of the idea of
soulmates as a psychologist yeah i i
don't really believe in that
so much you know but um but yeah and i i
do think that there's something to be
said you know for as you said just
focusing on yourself and and trying to
attract the right person i think that
our instant gratification society
whether it be you know always the
opportunity to you know swipe right and
you know see more and and constantly
compare it actually makes it harder to
really fix on somebody and you know
settle down on somebody like there have
even been studies that have shown
whether when it comes to like buying
peanut butter for example if you put a
customer in an aisle with 40 different
jars of peanut butter they just won't
buy one like they're just like geez you
know do i want the crunchy or do i want
the organic or do i want that you know
they go on and on and i think the same
thing can happen like with dating that
we just feel like we have too many
choices and it's hard to make one there
there was a i love these studies where
the study is is uh a trick
they had people fill out a survey and in
exchange you get a free t-shirt the
study was actually the t-shirt so these
people thought a form and they and then
with one group they said you get a free
green t-shirt
then with the other group they said you
get your choice between red green or
blue
the the people who after that they were
then asked how they felt about the the
gift the people who were given a choice
were rated it more negatively than those
who weren't the people got a free shirt
were like cool free shirt the people who
got the choice said i made the wrong
choice i should take in the blue one so
arranged marriage
you know i have clients that have
arranged marriages believe it or not
it's that work it's it's it's i was i
was surprised to see that it is not like
something that i i thought would never
happen you know but my my practice is in
new york and i'm not really seeing
clients as much actively now as i used
to in the past but i mean there's
actually a lot of people from cultures
where their parents are arranging
marriages and it's not as bad as it
sounds like their parents are not like
forcing them to get married to anybody
it's more like their parents are just
like lining up
first dates for them essentially and i
some of some of the clients that i would
have that didn't have that happening for
them they would be like i kind of wish
my parents would do that for me because
it tends to happen obviously not with
all but like in in the jewish
communities and with the um people who
have come from india they they tend to
have that happen more often at least in
just my colloquial observations those
sound like blind dates they're setting
up blind bags basically blind dates yeah
but that's different than saying you're
marrying this person now you're right
it's it's arranged marriage
opportunities you know like where
they're setting up blind dates with
somebody who's marriage-minded but
you're right it's not like they're just
saying hey go meet your husband and also
in most arranged marriages
the person has the option to nominate
it's not like the parent so you have to
marry this person like they pick someone
and then they get to know them and then
if they don't want to they do get the
the final say yeah but i think a lot of
not all the time obviously in certain
cultures that's something
a lot of cultures they can just say no
but then the parents are like don't do
this like we've worked hard at this
culture so there's pressure for sure
but it used to be with arranged
marriages where like the dad would go to
the dad of the the daughter and be like
how much money do i get we're doing this
salaries dowries and land grants and
things like that that's why a lot of the
royal families were doing it all
well one of the things that i notice in
that conversation about arranged
marriage is that both parties are going
into it with the understanding that they
are dating for marriage is something we
don't have anymore yeah yeah that's a
good point yeah and not only dating for
marriage right but giving up this idea
that there is a quote-unquote soulmate i
think it's a really toxic and
destructive idea that there's going to
be someone who will come along and
you'll just have an effortlessly good
relationship that's not going to be true
about friendships or relationships like
any kind of relationship that you have
and so it makes sense that in our
culture we would think that because as
you mentioned we're all about instant
gratification so yes of course i'm going
to meet someone who just like bends to
my will and everything which people
don't admit but that's kind of what they
say when they want to soulmate i want i
want someone who isn't going to require
that i change anything about myself or
give anything to and who it's just like
effortlessly pleasurable to be with
thanks for checking out this segment
from the tim cast irl podcast but if you
want to check out the full show live
tune in monday through friday at 8pm and
if you want more special access content
head over to timcast.com and become a
member your membership helps sustain
this company keep our journalists
employed makes this show happen and you
will get access to exclusive members
only segments of the tim cast irl
podcast and there's a massive library to
check out so again go to timcast.com or
tune in monday through friday at 8pm
we'll see you all there
you